with the short stories that you are
adapting an intervention of filming so
um what were they about the characters
what I mean killing animals it's about
like sort of these kids in the 90s that
is that way to kind of break free at
night and during the safety of Palo Alto
and sort of be learned more wild and on
the fringe yeah um yeah that's exactly
it I wanted to do a story about about
youth and growing up and as you growing
up you wanted you want to try to try to
snore the boundaries of what you can do
when he's not supposed to do it on it
maybe but when you're young you or you
feel your to fairness you feel feel
brave and fear isn't anything possible
infectious but then as you start growing
up realize what you do have the
percussions and consequences so it is a
film about these teenagers dealing with
it really grown-up issue for the first
time like getting to hit and run or
getting into very bad very bad fights
with each other or physical fights and
first time doing drunk drinking or doing
drugs for the first time it's like
really exploring this like that edge
when you start using your childhood
innocence and start realize that the
world you livin is not as safe as it is
not as not as secure as it can be and
though you live in the suburbs which are
varied and protected and desiring to
segregate to to keep you comfortable you
know yeah yeah his kids were who didn't
put out to who have been I guess maybe
it's better that's being too comfortable
and they try to get out of it and
through a really awesome of the Roses a
little bit more dangerous than they
thought a be in danger and getting what
they wanted sorry I don't think no
um did you go to Powell wat or even East
Palo Alto and kind of see the contrast
of those two worlds and how safe things
are before you cross the bridge to putt
East Palo Alto and the whole rock yeah I
went a while back when I was in
undergrad I went to school at converting
for my rent years so the bay area is in
a way like I feel might miss my best I
can home where I became Who I am and Tom
identity has person you know and it took
I check out to come out to when I was 19
Connie and I'm over being very shocked
by how how you know the suburbs there or
this is very drawing we're like one
areas super you know they did it after
wasn't comfortable on just like virtuous
by you have another row you know it's
just like but it's the suburbs so like
it's only Mouse apart but it feels like
a toy different escape and I can I think
also was very interesting too is like
how even though they did separating away
their search shows in high school the
different social classes mixed in
together you know so that's like this is
a nice nice contrast with not a lot of
tension but find very fascinating and
we're bouts do you hope to shoot this in
palo alto there's there's so many
different parts to it where do you
envision shooting a lot of it um I think
what I'm attracted to is there is a
there is a pot Alto that Zoe that we
have right now but you know I probably
too but there's a visitor Colorado you
know the suburbs that are very often
enough to go but I'm also interested in
seeing that the new construction was
me right now called on to live the new
developments because of the type
industry and how I was changing I think
what how long have a construction with
my imagination with with gated
communities or make mansions we're
almost like that I think are very
interesting to me because you feel like
environments that are like go to not
really grew apartments anyway you know
that are going to real places i think
you know like like it's it's singh was
fantastic so he could be interesting to
to explore and then it's provides for
how people live in it you know they come
his kids hang out in like parking lot
and I seventh Evans supermalls you know
or like does it go where else to go in
the way you know they do go to like
these in all cases many freeways
something that does anyone else have
grown cars which I was home and it's
like these cases I've seen me missing
even other things that happened in there
Parker